president putin arrives to the training
ground
and then it's show time a 45-minute
piece of theater for the
commander-in-chief in this six-day
exercise
a massive show of force by troops from
russia's strategically most important
western military district together with
belarusian forces right on the border
with europe right on nato's eastern
flank
a simulated counter-attack of a scenario
which they rehearse every four years
where a western coalition works to
unseat the power in belarus and take
over parts of the country joint
exercises overseen by presidents putin
in russia and lukashenko in belarus
always before alexander lukashenko liked
to play the reluctant military partner
in these drills but now he seems to have
convinced himself that this color
revolution scenario that they are
rehearsing about defending themselves
against here is exactly what europe
wants to do to him and that has pushed
him firmly into putin's corner
the direction of travel between these
two men one year after huge street
protests against lukashenko's rule is
going one way towards closer integration
and that's militarily too with russia
now maintaining a fairly constant
military presence in belarus with a new
joint training ground right up against
its border with poland and lithuania
[Music]
about 200 000 servicemen private
division about 760 units of military
equipment 15 ships and up to 80 aircraft
once again we have shown our readiness
to provide safety for the union state
these could be the biggest exercises on
europe's border since the cold war no
nato observers invited they never are
we are closely observing the zapat
exercise
while each country has the right to
conduct military exercises
limited transparency the wider context
of the maneuvers
and the accompanying hybrid activities
raise
our concerns
but russia tends to inflate the numbers
to scare the west and impress the viewer
back home
and it is impressive a piece of muscle
flexing to make sure that russia's armed
forces are ready for whatever threats or
opportunities present themselves next
dana magnay sky news at the mouliner
training ground russia